It's a good question.
Uh,
and it's a little bit about our history.
You know,
we've,
we've become so disassociated with
agriculture,
both with the culture of agriculture.
I'm with agriculture itself.
We are one generation and in some cases
two generations removed from that.
And as you get more and more removed
from how food is grown,
who's,
who's growing it,
where it's coming from,
how it's getting to you,
uh,
the easier it is to be completely
disassociated from the decisions about
all those things.
So,
so I think part of my job and part of
the job of stone barns is to say,
Hey,
wait a minute.
This is part of the pleasures of living.
And these are decisions that are being
made every day by farmers all around the
country and all around the world.
And we need to buy into this thing.
So as an eater you have a kind of
responsibility.
And for some people like chefs,
I think it's a greater responsibility
for other people like eaters.
It's just,
it's an everyday thought process to,
to put your money where your mouth is
and to understand that you're voting.
Look,
we're in a political season and we say
we vote every once every four years.
And so many people get frustrated that
their vote really has no say and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
Well,
this is an opportunity three times a day
to vote with your fork and two,
to make a huge impact on,
on how people think,
uh,
about,
supporting food and how food is grown.
And that,
that seems to me to be a very positive
message.
Uh,
and,
and it's,
uh,
it's one that that could lead again
with,
with the flavor,
with the potential for real pleasure.
Uh,
and,
and I think people are turned on to that
and excited by that.
And,
and,
and we're just,
we're just starting to feel this,
this wave of interest,
which hopefully will translate into
things like,
like new political reality.